non-minimalists
how do you guys relate to religion to
the lifestyle of minimalism
well rob when ryan and i talk about
minimalism we're talking about
minimalism as a lifestyle in particular
i mean
there are other forms of minimalism
obviously when i talk about
donald judd or brad easton ellis and
laurie moore
um when we talk about minimalism as a
lifestyle it's
living a meaningful life with less
trying to figure out the things that
truly add value to our life getting rid
of that which is superfluous
to make room for that which is important
and so
how do you how do you relate that to
religion or spirituality
well historically if you think about the
word religion
in the middle is this l-i-g it comes
from the latin
the latin is this word root is this lig
is this word legare which means to bind
or
connect so so that's where ligament
comes from because it binds these two
things together so
if you think about the etymology like
the structure of the word religion
religion is what holds you together
so that that's it's intent otherwise
life pulls you in a hundred different
directions you like disintegrate so
religion was always
what are the practices or rituals what
are the things you do
that hold you together
so what you all have been doing with
this message of minimalism
is very religious at its core you're
inviting people to be held together by
something other than
unthinking uncritical consumerism just
the accumulation
there's more to life than the
accumulation of dead objects
um so when people talk about religion as
a bad thing but then they say but my
friend they do that religiously
yeah they do that on a regular basis
because it helps give coherence
and holds them together now the problem
in modern culture for many people is
religion did the opposite it actually
split things apart
it created tribes not community yeah
yeah yeah
so it like collapsed in on itself for
many people that was their experience
which is fine but it doesn't mean that
we won't just find other things to be
religious about
so the person's like i walk my dog every
morning i take a jog training for yeah
of course you do
yeah i have a meal with my kid every day
yeah of course you do there are these
things that you do that
hold you together they bind you bind you
to a sense of larger
purpose meaning divinity um
binds you to other people yeah yeah so
what you all do is actually very
religious wow
you didn't see that coming no you made
me you made me feel good about it
well because you know what's interesting
is like when we first started this
people were like what are you doing
starting a cult
and i was like no not a cult because
because cult leads itself you know
because once a cult gets big enough it
becomes religion
but uh but you know i actually really
like what we do
because there's no dogmatics to it in
religion in the sense that you talked
about i
can actually own that and be like yeah i
i totally
there there is a religious thing going
on as far as
looking at something greater than what's
in front of us
absolutely this is and it wasn't just
well you think about it in terms of
religion for many people was a head game
what do you believe
like you said no dog but what do you
believe how is your
mental furniture arranged that became
but historically religion was always a
path
like how do you live yeah like it was
economic it was political
it was a way of ordering your life and
ordering
the world like in the bible over and
over again the bible is about how does
the world
get ordered um if there's a widening gap
between rich and poor
that's destructive for everybody if you
don't live with the earth
in the earth in a sustainable way
everything falls
apart so the question is how does the
world get ordered and in some senses
what you've done is create a space
that raises questions for people about
how do you order your world
because there are ways of ordering the
world that just lead
to despair and a sense of empty what is
going on here and there are ways
that lead you to community and love and
connection and all that
you guys are way more religious than you
realize that
is a great tagline minimalism the
philosophy on how to order your world
i was thinking you're going to say
minimalism we are way more religious
that's that's the number two this is
from uh
the criticism section on the minimalist
wikipedia page
um so a few things in here about
religion according to the dallas morning
news more than a few have ascribed
religious underpinnings to the
minimalist work
but milburn insists the minimalists are
not a faith-based business
and we don't believe in the law of
attraction here's one that rob will
appreciate
in an article titled your minimalist
lifestyle is quasi-religious anti-poor
[ __ ]
vice magazine condemned the minimalists
as quote glowing examples of as
asceticism as
solution ascribing deeply religious
motives to their movement because they
are
quote a pair of white dudes who travel
the world to proclaim the joys of
simplicity
and just happen to be close friends with
evangelical legend
rob bell just so happened
yeah this is this is what is where is
this coming no this is an article that
was written about us
uh the article goes on to claim yeah
blah blah blah anyway um
i guess what rob's saying is yeah we the
vice is right yeah damn we didn't even
know it they knew it before we knew it
pretty much pretty much every wisdom
tradition
had in it some space
for uh
i was gonna say that's not the right
word for
living i would call it closer to the
earth
you generally find these polarities of
feasting and fasting
sometimes what is needed is a
celebration of the abundance of life
a big table with lots of food and
everybody comes to it
yeah sometimes sometimes you need to
feast
yeah but other times fasting which would
be simply
going without is how you realign
how you awaken um and so you can see
anytime somebody parks themselves
at one of those two you've missed that
sometimes
it's time for feasting and sometimes
it's time
for fasting so so the aesthetic the one
who withdraws or the one who
intentionally goes
with less or without that's always been
one of the ways that people found their
soul lived with integrity realigned
re-centered experienced rebirth
so it's funny when the aesthetic is
spoken of of
derisively because that's like a
thousand-year-old human pattern of one
of the ways that people have helped
check themselves and realign themselves
you know what i mean yeah it's just
fascinating to see it seen as like
sort of trivial or something when yeah
the witness
of like the cloud of witnesses across
history has been yeah sometimes you need
to
go live in a cave for a bit sometimes
you need to give away your stuff that's
that's all part of the thing i think any
new idea
or i mean minimalism isn't a new idea
but maybe an
an old idea for a new any old idea that
appears unfamiliar
yeah what's interesting it gets
criticized so the the problem now that
we have you know especially around 2008
we had this whole collapse is
we we realized for the first time like
massive amounts of debt we spend 1.2
trillion dollars a year on non-essential
goods
uh in the united states alone and and so
you look at something like that and you
realize like
oh we're wasting our money which we have
to work a lot of time
to get to buy things we don't want or
need we're going into debt
we have this huge problem with over
indulgent
over consumption and i think around the
crash
it was a reset it was a crash for people
to realize like oh
maybe the way that we're living is is
wrong some people made some changes
around the time
ryan and i um we we stumbled across this
whole minimalism thing
but then over the last decade i think we
faced a new problem
with social media and and 24-hour news
cycles
every minute of every day now we're
facing this
over we're overly distracted as well so
not only are we over
over consuming stuff but we're over
consuming
discrete inputs and you know we're
being bombarded with hundreds of
thousands of discrete inputs every
single day
and what we're saying is you don't have
to
be an ascetic and go live in a cave but
maybe you can
look at what what their recipe is and
tweeze out a few ingredients and see
what's appropriate for your own life
yeah yeah maybe like one day a week you
don't check your email
and for many people that creates a
low-grade panic but 20 years ago you
didn't
have emails so a thing that you didn't
have like think about that feeling when
you misplaced your phone
and just what that sends like
neurochemically through your body the
agitation level
of a thing that you didn't use to know
existed
yeah like a tiny little machine that you
carry in your pocket you now if you
misplace it
my whole life is on that phone yeah you
start going through the phone so this is
brand new
immediately this is brand new humans
haven't ever had
this sort of experience that we're
having with these machines
makes me think about how you brand new
you talk about the molecules being brand
new and the atoms being brand new at a
certain point
and uh yeah where is technology going to
take us yeah it's like we're in it right
now we're in the brand new right now
yes yes and we're just now learning like
you think about
how the algorithms and social media are
bent towards the outrageous
yeah so this person comments hey i
really enjoyed that
the algorithm's like whatever this
person's like you suck
heat center throbbing heat center you
know what i mean and then this person
piles on
i mean the machines are literally tilted
towards the outrageous
i mean if you if you understood that
you could become president
[Laughter]
wait a minute that the machines are bent
in a particular direction so
every person who's like how did 2016
happen
much better question how
aware are you of your role in that
because every time you click something
outrageous
yeah you are reaffirming that the
algorithms are bent in the proper
direction
and that's the the biggest problem with
with the advertising model i i
appreciate that you don't do
advertisements in your podcast and um
there are a few other people out there
who don't and and the reason we don't
is when we want people to support us for
the right
reasons you know thank thank you to our
patreon supporters who who support us
and keep us in this podcast space but
what
what i've realized with the advertising
model is it's
only about aggregating eyeballs because
the more eyeballs that are on
your newspaper or tv show or whatever it
is
the more they can charge for advertising
and so they no longer need to
add value to an audience they simply
need to aggregate or herd an
audience to their platform
and in doing so they make more revenue
well how do you do that
you you amp up the the outrage and then
of course
as you say we're complicit in in the
clicking and the viewing
and then not turning it off yeah so
yeah going back to spirituality
spirituality is a heightened awareness
of what these forms that we have created
are doing to us because spirit animates
forms
so we are surrounded by these forms and
these new forms are shaping us
so you can see people waking up to wait
these machines and the algorithms
are actually doing things to us and we
have tremendous power to shape them
to resist to form neural pathways
there's always an empowerment of they're
doing this to us
but they don't have to yeah we can set
it down
we can not click all that
you